Hey youtubers it’s Charlie Happy Game Of
Thrones Day!
this is my last bonus video before the Season
4 premiere.
I think we were all about to explode from
excitement.
here’s what’s going down.
This will be my Top 10 Moments from Season
3 just as a final look back.
Then at the end of the video I’m going to
go over the giveaway rules and what my Game
of Thrones video schedule will be going forward.
Careful for season 3 spoilers if you’re
not caught up yet, but let’s not waste any
time.
Number 10 - Jon Snow Becomes A Man
A seminal time in the life of any teenager.
This wasn’t so much Jon Snow losing his
virginity as it was Ygritte taking his virginity.
You get the sense that she was the real brains
of that operation and Jon was just happy to
oblige.
It’s a nice reversal of gender roles.
For instance, had everything played out in
King’s Landing and Ygritte been a member
of the court, it would have been told from
a much more male perspective.
Even though Cersei wields a lot of sexual
authority over men, she’s much much older.
I don’t remember it being spelled out explicitly
in the books, but I think it’s implied that
when she was Jon Snow and Ygritte’s age,
Jaime was her only sexual partner.
At least before she was married to Robert
Baratheon.
As much fun as it was to watch that scene
in the cave, it was even better listening
to Kit Harington and Rose Leslie talk about
how awful and awkward it was on set that day.
I think that Kit Harington was also still
in a leg cast.
So imagine him limping into that hot spring.
Number 9 - Brienne Versus the Bear
This was kind of a meta moment because first
off you have bad ass Brienne holding her own
against a freaking bear with a wooden sword.
So it’s just awesome.
Then you have Jaime’s change of heart and
rescue.
In reality it wasn’t his fighting skill
that saved them.
He would have been shredded in seconds.
It was just the threat of what Tywin Lannister
would do if he were hurt.
More than he had already been.
I loved how the whole event invoked this classic
sense of chivalry that Brienne believed in
so much.
Most of the time she’s the one being chivalrous.
But it was such a big moment for both of them.
Brienne not dying and Jaime doing something
selfless for a change.
Number 8 - The Night’s Watch Rebellion
Dirty old Craster and the old Bear never saw
it coming.
First we have to acknowledge that it was Burn
Gorman of Torchwood authoring the debacle.
That was a nice meta Doctor Who fandom moment.
But then you have the oh shit realization
that with Jeor Mormont dead and the Night’s
Watch in open revolt, who is going to get
everyone ready for the Wildling Attack.
I’m not even talking about the Army itself.
They don’t even have a chance against the
small raiding party that Jon Snow was part
of.
I think we all shared a collective moment
of triumph when Old Craster ate it.
Quickly followed by the horror on Samwell’s
face before he grabbed Gilly and took off.
Number 7 - Thoros of Myr Brings Back Beric
Dondarrion
Flaming swords aside, this was a huge deal
because it established that the dead can be
made whole again.
Not just reanimated wights, but brought back
to their normal state.
Beric Dondarrion said that there were some
side effects.
Like pieces of you would get left behind each
time you came back.
Melisandre is pretty amazed when she finds
out how many times Beric has been brought
back, so it seems like each priest or priestess
of the Red God expresses their powers in different
ways.
I think she’ll be able to do it before Winds
of Winter or Dream of Spring is over.
So anyone who’s worried about characters
dying.
As long as they’re in proximity to someone
with the powers of the Red God, there’s
always a chance they’ll be brought back.
Number 6 - Jon Snow Climbs The Wall
This was one of the biggest action set pieces
of the season and involved a lot of really
cool CG integration.
I remember reading about the sheer size of
the Wall in the books.
But until the show came along you really just
had to imagine what it looked like in your
head.
I think they did a great job of interpreting
just how massive it is.
In the books George RR Martin made it 700
feet tall.
And I feel like it becomes a whole character
in and of itself.
Like the wall is a character in the story.
All I can think about now is one, when are
we going to get to see or read about it being
built and two, will we ever see someone blow
the true horn of winter and bring it crashing
down.
It’s still just a legend that blowing the
horn will destroy the wall.
Let me know if you think we’ll see this
happen at some point.
Number 5 - Ramsay Snow Tortures Theon for
an entire Season.
The final act of torture was clearly the worst,
but there’s no promise after that the tortue
won’t continue into the early part of season
4.
So as far as we know, he’s still being tortured
right now.
As bad as Theon was before Season 3, I feel
like he’s endured enough.
Everything about the character as he is right
now just makes you feel sorry for him.
Sorry for the circumstances that made him
feel like he had to betray his adopted family
and sorry for what Ramsay Snow has done to
him.
There is the promise that he’ll get out
eventually.
There was footage from the trailer with Theon
on horseback and he wasn’t running away.
Number 4 - Sam Kills White Walker
I remember the first time I saw this, I had
to rewind and watch it again because I couldn’t
tell if he dropped the obsidian dagger before
he ran off with Gilly.
Samwell for all his faults is one of the first
new people to figure out that one of the White
Walkers’ biggest weaknesses is Obsidian
or dragon glass.
Whatever you want to call it.
I’m really hoping that he’s able to educate
the rest of the Night’s Watch in time.
There was that ominous shot of the white walker
in one of the season 4 trailers.
Number 3 - Jaime Hand Chopped Off
This had to be the defining moment for the
first part of the season.
The death of Ned Stark kind of already told
us that no one was safe, but getting his hand
chopped off let you know that George RR Martin
and the show wasn’t afraid to permanently
maim it’s lead characters.
It’s such an oh shit moment just because
of the spectacle and because they just slammed
to black right as Jaime started screaming.
But it really made me wonder what the hell
was going to happen to the character.
It’s not like they have hospitals and in
the books, the Brave Companions basically
treat Jaime and Brienne like trash until they
made it back to Roose Bolton.
Number 2 - Daenerys Becomes the Breaker of
Chains
This mostly refers to her taking the Unsullied
and exacting revenge against Kraznys.
It was one of those big moments that HBO teased
in all the clips.
Her activating Drogon so to speak using High
Valyrian.
It became this amazing CG sequence of her
burning everything in sight and marching away
with this massive army.
Such a huge win for her when you consider
that there’s so much civil war still going
on in Westeros while all this is happening.
Number 1 - The Red Wedding
I don’t think there’s any Season 3 WTF
list that doesn’t list this as the number
one moment.
It was one of THE most talked about moments
on Television last year.
And most people don’t even get HBO or watch
the show.
Before this George RR Martin and the show
already had meme’s for slaughtering main
characters wholesale.
But the Red Wedding became this meta cultural
event for the world.
First there were all the reaction videos,
like Maisie Williams.
Queen of Vines.
Then there were all the parodies.
You can really gage the popularity of something
by how much it gets parodied.
And just in terms of television, this was
the most parodied event all year.
I think my favorite was probably Maisie Williams.
Her reaction video was only six seconds, but
it perfectly summed up the spirit of every
single other video that followed.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what your favorite season 3 moment
was and which event you're most looking forward
to in season 4.
Everyone is waiting on the edge of their seat
for the purple wedding.
Which is funny because all the book readers
are kind of grumbling that George RR Martin
never called it the purple wedding.
Just another example of how pop culture can
take something and change it in the larger
context.
Here’s details on the giveaway again with
rules.
It’s super simple.
Just as a way to say thank you to all you
guys, I’m picking one random subscriber
from the comments on each of my episode reviews.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on my episode
1 review, episode 2 and so on.
Winners will be announced Monday nights during
my Q&A videos.
Here’s the rules.
You can only win a giveaway once.
So if you’ve won something from me in the
past, you can’t win again.
You also have to be nice, this is supposed
to be a fun way to talk about a show we love.
So if I think you’re being mean or trolling.
I’ll just delete your comment and at worst
ban you from the channel.
So remember to play nice.
Tonight I’ll be posting my episode 1 review
about 3 hours after it airs.
You can follow me on twitter and facebook
for updates on when videos are coming.
While we all hold our breath for episode 1
to get here, check out my top 10 characters
here and click here for all my season 4 videos.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!